we're kicking it in the 70s and there
was pet rocks in the 70s the Creator
Gary Dahl he sold a million of these
that is amazing it's just so fun it's
amazing so we we decided to see if we
would all do some pet rocks and I'd love
for you to Sam yours is looking very
festive will you will you tell us about
your pet rock I was I was inspired by
Angry Birds oh the movie as my kids love
Angry Birds the movie so I thought well
I'll make a new character and uh I made
I made Blossom so sweet
all right who's next I'll go next okay
so mine was inspired by Fraggle Rock
does she have a name her name is cabbie
she does look like a major vegetable
promotion she's a promoter of veggies
and yes yeah all right I like this
wrapping job that you did over here you
went outside
it's a little bit delicate but I kind of
went I started wrapping the yellow
things around and it kind of made me
think of a little bit Hulk Hogan but
then I was really sad about the extra
rock that was just sitting there and I
thought maybe maybe my pet rock could
have a pet rock oh God and it kind of
makes it stand up you know so he's a
very supportive pet rock for the pet
rock he's like I got your back buddy
[Applause]
what is yours
um I I don't I'm not quite sure what
this is inspiring I might need some help
from my college
yeah she's a little cheeky she's a
little cheeky
I do like the way that I like her yeah
she's glamorous she's very feminine too
yeah yeah she does she she kind of does
embarrasses okay
I understood
for dummies this is Billy and Camilla
done
okay
Billy is Sam in the show we're married
and understood and this is our marriage
and
um
representative of our marriage well
that's how you interpreted it and that's
the whole point Sebastian with your
fabulous nails and accessories thank you
what did you bring to the pets I'm a bit
of a rock purist
um
it's on it and I was like nah and then I
put like one of the little pipe cleaners
on it I was like I just I really I think
it fits in your hand real well I think
what's important you know it's all about
this you know it's a nudist exactly
you're my 70s
exactly right that's mistake all right
now the last question can I rapid fire
each one of you to say one thing that
you wish either would come back or at
least stick around from that era Sookie
starting with you okay solid balls
Joshua
um I would probably say the fashion I
think some flat pants okay everything's
got way too skinny okay I'm gonna be
boring and say architecture I think this
is my honest answer
because it's not boring that's brilliant
I'm gonna say the music I feel like you
can't quite beat the 70s era for a music
Camilla I would say the hangs like the
Laurel Canyon hangs the music Gatherings
like going to someone's house and like
sitting around and playing music
and like you know going to someone's
house and playing guitar and singing in
like a group and you know like we could
we could do that sometimes
um I would I would probably have to say
the originality I think everything in
that era was like new and different than
it had ever been and like just like in
every genre of music and art and movies
you know now it feels like everything's
a copy of a copy of a copy you know
that's a great answer all right so the
first three episodes of Daisy John and
the six on Prime video there you can
catch that now and new episodes every
Friday and just thank you guys thank you
for coming and playing
I will be right back
[Music]